THE COUNTRY SO WE CAN DEAL
WITH THESE DEMOCRATS IN THE
PRESS AND ALL THEY ARE TRYING TO
STOP.
>> Sean: MARK MEADOWS, THIS IS
A BIG REPORT BY
CATHERINE HERRIDGE, ALSO BIG
NEWS BY JOHN SOLOMON, BUT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE, WAS ALREADY
KNOWN WHAT JAMES COMEY TESTIFIED
TO IN OCTOBER OF 2016, THE
RUSSIAN LIES OF HILLARY CLINTON
THAT WERE PAID FOR WERE IN FACT
UNVERIFIABLE.
NOW THEY ARE GOING DEEPER.
NOW WE KNOW THIS WOMAN, KAVALEC,
AT THE STATE DEPARTMENT, NOW WE
KNOW THAT BRUCE OHR, BECAUSE OF
YOUR INTERROGATION, AND JIM'S
INTERROGATION, BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS, THEY ALL SAID THEY WARNED
JAMES COMEY.
THEY WERE THE FBI.
THEY TOLD HIM EVERYTHING ABOUT
THE DOSSIER BEING PHONY AND THEY
USED IT AS THE BULK OF
INFORMATION TO GET THE WARRANT
TO SPY ON THE CAMPAIGN OF TRUMP
ANYWAY.
WHERE IS THAT TAKING IS?
>> WHAT WE SEE IS JAMES COMEY
WENT THROUGH NOT ONLY YELLOW
FLASHING LIGHTS, BUT HE WENT
THROUGH RED STOPLIGHTS TO TRY TO
GET THIS PRESIDENT AND INDICT
THIS PRESIDENT.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT NOT ONLY THE
GOOD WORK THAT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE REPORTED IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE ARE SEEING,
WHAT WE KNEW, BUT WE KNOW THAT
CHRISTOPHER STEELE NOT ONLY WAS
TALKING TO THE DOJ, BUT WAS
TALKING TO THE FBI, WAS TALKING
TO THE MEDIA, TALKING TO THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
HE WAS TALKING TO ANYBODY WHO
WOULD LISTEN --
>> Sean: HE WAS TRYING TO TALK
TO MUELLER TO BRUCE OHR.
HE WAS HITTING MESSAGES TO THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE.
>> HE WAS SENDING SMOKE SIGNALS
EVERYWHERE TRYING TO GET SOMEONE
TO TAKE THIS PARTICULAR STORY
THAT WAS FALSE.
THE FBI KNEW IT WAS FALSE.
THEY KNEW THEY HAD CREDIBILITY
PROBLEMS.
AND YET, THEY CONTINUE TO SPY ON
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
>> Sean: JIM JORDAN, DIDN'T HE
SAY, COMEY, THAT HE DOESN'T SPY?
[LAUGHTER]
>> HERE IS MY CATHERINE STORY IS
SO IMPORTANT, WHY PEOPLE ARE
COMING FORWARD IN
MR. HERBERT'S INVESTIGATION, THE
REASON THEY ARE COMING
FORWARD IS BECAUSE THERE IS A
NEW SHERIFF IN TOWN.
THAT IS BILL BARR.
BILL BARR HAS ANNOUNCED HE WILL
GET -- NEVER FORGET WHAT HE
SAID.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS ON YOUR
SHOW.
HE SAID THERE IS A FAILURE OF
LEADERSHIP AND HE UPPER ECHELON
OF THE FBI.
THERE IS A BASIS FOR HIS CONCERN
ABOUT THE SPYING THAT TOOK PLACE
AND HE USED TERMS THAT SHOULD
SCARE EVERY AMERICAN.
UNAUTHORIZED SURVEILLANCE AND